you will never have seen anything like
you're about to see in this video we had
500 people accept Islam in the remotes
Matic salutes tribe but what happens
after these people accept Islam we
mobilized our entire team and headed out
for a six-day program for these new
Muslims who are completely isolated in a
remote village up in the mountains they
first learnt about Allah
[Music]
they then started to learn the actions
forward do al capone an imam come with
my muscle Ganesha everyone got together
and lined up for that first solo
send me along William and Henry there
everything comes in steps it was time to
memorize the mother of God
my doobie
everyone was in groups with their
teachers memorizing the verses of the
Quran it was an incredible sight to see
so many people learning how to worship
Allah at the end of six days so many of
the attendees could do we do perform the
entire solar in Arabic and teach others
to do the same
[ __ ] this is what you call new Muslim
support so I have a question for you
will you let this project die or will
you allow us to continue these salar
camps and teach these new users click
the button and support the Dower
now and don't forget to share this
incredible video so others can learn
this method of teaching new Muslims and
you share in the reward for free
[Music]